If only someone had given Nick Fury the same
kind of warning Santa Claus once gave Ralphie
Parker.
"You’ll shoot your eye out, kid."
Ever since Samuel L. Jackson revealed in January
2018 that Captain Marvel would feature Fury
without his signature eyepatch, fans everywhere
have been wondering the same thing: would
the newest MCU entry explain how he actually
lost his eye?
Jackson and the whole Captain Marvel team,
including star Brie Larson and co-directors
Anna Boden and Ryan Fleck, have kept quiet
about that particular element of the film,
but now we know the truth.
Captain Marvel does indeed see Fury sustain
the injury that ultimately costs him his eye.
In doing so, the film also answers a mystery
that's gone unsolved for 11 years, since the
debut of Iron Man and the beginning of the
MCU as we know it.
Spoilers ahead, obviously.
So, here's what happens with Fury and his
infamous eye in Captain Marvel: Carol Danvers'
best friend and fellow Air Force pilot Maria
Rambeau boards a ship with Fury after evading
the Kree Starforce, who are actually the main
bad guys in the film.
Unbeknownst to Maria and Fury, Goose, the
fuzzy orange cat Fury often cuddled with and
cooed at throughout the duration of Captain
Marvel is in tow as well.
It’s worth noting here that Goose isn't
actually a cat: he's a Flerken, an alien creature
who only takes a feline appearance.
And it’s Goose who plays a big part in getting
Fury and company to safety during the film’s
final act.
When he realizes the cat has made his way
onto his ship, Fury scoops Goose up and thanks
him for helping them on their mission to save
Earth, protecting the shape-shifting Skrulls,
and retrieving the Tesseract.
As Maria and Fury attempt to escape the Kree,
Goose opens his mouth and extends several
octopus-like arms to grab the Tesseract and
swallow it whole.
Luckily, Goose has a pocket dimension in which
he's able to "store entire universes" and
access them at will.
Naturally, Fury believes that Goose would
never hurt him, since he’s on their side.
As Fury delivers baby-talk to Goose, the cat
takes a swipe at his face, leaving several
scratch marks across Fury's eyebrow and lid.
Fury and Maria assume that the scratch is
nothing major, but the injury only gets worse
as the film wraps up.
By the very end of the movie, we see Fury
wearing a metallic-looking cover over the
injured eye which is now missing entirely.
Agent Phil Coulson steps into Fury's office,
hands him a case full of fake eyes, and jokes
that he has a big decision to make.
He then asks if it's true that the Kree burned
Fury's eye out, a rumor Fury neither confirms
nor denies, signaling that he's learned to
stay cautious of everyone around him after
his life-changing adventures with Captain
Marvel, the Kree, and the Skrulls.
The injury Fury suffers in Captain Marvel
also connects nicely to the only explicit
statement Fury has given about his eye in
the MCU thus far.
Fans have wondered what happened to Fury's
eye since we first met him in Iron Man, but
he's made only ever one direct mention of
it:
"Last time I trusted someone, I lost an eye."
Though the someone Fury trusted is really
a something, that mystery is finally solved:
Fury trusted Goose to be a friendly companion,
thanked him for his role in completing the
mission, and eventually needs to wear an eyepatch
for the rest of his life because of it.
A cat-like alien probably isn't the untrustworthy
entity fans were thinking of when Fury first
spoke about losing his eye, but it's now officially
canon in the MCU.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.